eh bien écoutez je pense qu'il est temps
il est temps de parler d'eux à venir
ivoire donc je pensais pas être à ip
autant par un film marvel mais il est
vrai que ça fait dix ans que
ce marvel teasé que thanos et ise comme
ennemi ultime est bon sens j'étais
vraiment pressé le voir et franchement
j'étais pas déçu du tout mais vraiment
pas déçu du tout à tel point que j'ai
limite plus apprécié ce film que star
wars lutte j'étais tellement vraiment
comme un dingue que j'attendais vraiment
cette sortie mais en tout cas avant que
cette vidéo commence je voulais vous
informer que du coup je fais un concours
sur twitter pour vous faire gagner une
figurine pop sur marvel et les avengers
donc si vous voulez participer c'est
d'en laisser le lien est dans la
description en gros il suffit de
retweeter de me suivre sur twitter pour
participer il y aura une ou deux
figurines je me souviens plus trop du
coup je vous laisse vérifier
alors du coup il ya eu un jour environ
de battement là du coup j'ai vu ce film
heyer malheureusement bon ça c'est fini
vers minuit donc c'est un peu tard pour
tourner une vidéo du coup je me suis dit
bon c'est pas grave je me laissais un
jours de battement histoire de laisser
fermenter un petit peu la chose est bon
sens et j'arrive pas à me sortir le truc
de la tête genre j'ai passé ma journée à
penser infinity ward à faire des
recherches et toi regarder des trucs sur
l'univers des comics parce que ça m'a
marqué ce film et j'ai envie de
m'intéresser encore plus à l'univers
étant débutant dans cette saga qui est
les marvel que j'ai débuté il ya environ
vraiment on va dire vraiment vraiment
à deux mois on va dire du coup j'étais
vraiment comme un dingue là et je suis
j'en ressors des images plein la tête
vraiment je suis ravie au plus haut
point donc bien évidemment c'est une
vidéo 100% spoil donc je vous conseille
si vous ne voulez pas être spoilé de ne
pas regarder cette vidéo parce que je ne
peux pas faire une critique sans ce pôle
est en fait ça sert à rien j'ai je veux
vous partagez mon avis comme je fais
pour les très grosses sorties les très
gros film mais bien évidemment je dois
spoil sinon ça sera un parler du film
pour moi donc revenue voir cette vidéo
quand vous aurez vu le film si vous ne
l'avez toujours pas vu ah oui j'ai
oublié de vous dire aussi il y à un
sondage dans la description en gros vous
avez dit questions à répondre sur
infinity ward je faire une vidéo
sondages comme j'avais fait sur rail
potter et star wars et du coup vous
allez répondre aux questions c'est dans
la description ou le commentaire épinglé
et du cou j'analyserai tout ça en vidéo
et puis je ferai un live dimanche aussi
pour
débattre avec vous sur ce film pour ceux
qui l'ont vu et je ferai intervenir des
abonnés et tous pour avoir leur avis en
live vraiment lève de voix à voit donc
voilà c'est enfin s'est dit maintenant
aller attaquons le film qu'est ce que
j'ai à dire sur ce film c'est parti donc
tout d'abord remettons nous dans le
contexte donc les marvel c'est assez
quand même bisounours on va dire parce
que du coup voilà il ya les gentils à
chaque fois ça mais le film intègre le
héros le film est fait pour le héros
pour l'intégrer à l'histoire le
découvrir et cetera le mettre en avant
vivre ses aventures il ya un méchant
voilà il ya toujours des péripéties
galère puis le battre est fait enfin pas
très facilement bill le bas toujours à
la fin et voilà c'est tout est fini tout
est rose tout est beau là le film là
c'est totalement l'inversé est bon sens
a fait ça fait extrêmement bizarre
venant d'un marvel parce que du coup
j'ai dû aller de surprise en surprise en
fait je m'attendais pas du tout à ça le
film est fait pour introduire thanos
pour découvrir la noce pour voir sa
puissance voir cet ennemi qui est ise
depuis 10 ans et ça fait très bizarre au
début on commence le film in media res
on commence direct dans l'action avec un
combat contre thanos voilà tort se fait
capturer il est limite en train de
mourir il va être tué en fait ça prouve
déjà la dangerosité de la noce basque eu
tort c'est quand même un dieu ça le
prouve
il le prouve d'ailleurs à la fin avec sa
puissance est tout et avec le
stormbreaker mais thor est sur le point
de mourir en fait etc il est vraiment
tenu par thanos par la main donc cette
ça monte sa dangerosité et son pouvoir
s'en suit d'ailleurs un petit combat
contre hulk qui va avoir des
répercussions parce que du coup hulk ne
voudra pas pu revenir
on peut supposer d'ailleurs que lucas a
eu peur a eu peur de thanos et ne veut
plus revenir
cubana on ne peut plus se transformer et
direct on commence avec un gros combat
de titans et tout c'est assez
impressionnant ça c'est incroyable
et puis surtout le truc que je
m'attendais le moins au monde
l'eau qui meurent comme une merde dès le
début l'eau qui se fait sauvagement tuée
par tano ce dès le début et ça c'est
incroyable
loki on commence à être habitué à le
voir tout ça il est toujours en train de
survivre en a long à droite à gauche en
sait jamais dit trop yvain sait jamais
trop comment ils se comportent tout ça
même si on sait qu'il est toujours du
côté des méchants
hélas pas d'hésitation ça fait un peu
comme dans comment dire dans kingman
avec je me souviens plus des noms mais
l'agent qui forment le héros il se fait
sauvagement tué d'un coup tu as qu un
coup de revolver et puis ça ou à la
basse qu'à chaque fois les gentils bon
ils sont capturés parce que les méchants
ils veulent aller tuer lentement et
sûrement et cetera ils s'en sortent
toujours la danse état qu il le shop
peuvent ils ne tuent c'est fini il meurt
l'eau qui est mort ça ou c'est terminé
on le verra plus
c'est assez incroyable déjà dès le début
on sent que thanos voilà c'est quelqu'un
d'incroyablement fort qui n'est pas du
tout là pour rigoler et déjà c'était un
très bon début du film on était du g2 me
sentais déjà stressés pour la suite je
me disais [ __ ] là ça sent vraiment pas
bon quoi ça sent vraiment pas bon
d'ailleurs j'aimerais féliciter vraiment
marvel là dessus parce que du coup ça
fait
vingt films il me semble qu'il y as eu
vraiment on va dire du mc u etc
et du coup ça fait dix ans que thanos et
ise en tant qu'ennemi ultime ennemis
suprême et on était je prends l'exemple
je compare beaucoup et star wars
parce que c'est l'habitude c'est star
wars c'est toujours été la base pour moi
et par rapport à star wars 7 et star
wars 8 on était hype et comme des
dingues la séparer ça fait dix ans qu'on
a été bon ça fait moins que entre
guillemets moins que star wars même si
ça faisait dix ans qui a fait un nouveau
star wars et on est hype et comme des
oufs et la hype elle est toujours là
elle est toujours présente et j'ai
vraiment été déçu à 0 au moment du film
et c'est incroyable alors que star wars
et beaucoup de déçus tout cela pour le
moment j'ai pas eu j'ai vu c'est
vraiment il n'y a pas eu de liste suis
déçu star wars c'est nul et séraphin
avengers nuls tout ça et c'est dans la
fumée était vraiment bon et bon sang
thanos qu'est ce que c'est un un méchant
incroyable pareil pour ensuite les
équilibres des héros en fait chaque
héros et bien mis en avant que ça soit
les gardiens de la galaxie que ça soit
docteur strange iron man etc
chaque héros à sa place chaque héros est
bien présent il ya personne qui mis de
côté et ça ça fait franchement plaisir
chacun son utilité chacun et l'a fait
partie du combat et et ça c'était
quelque chose que je trouve vraiment
difficile parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
rôles assez l'affrontement ultime ils
sont quasiment tous réunis et du coup
chacun ait réussi à être mis en valeur
avec ses qualités ses défauts etc
et c'était franchement bien bien fait
bon maintenant enfin faut vraiment qu'on
parle de thanos et c'est parce que
c'était quand même incroyable
thanos c'est quand même
un méchant qui attisait depuis dix ans
qui est un peu enfin semi éternelle
c'est un titan etc
et c'est lui qui tire les ficelles
depuis le début et c'est pour avoir les
pires d'infinité et bon sang qu'est-ce
que les méchants et tano aussi les il
est charismatique il est intelligent il
est humain c'est ça change en fait parce
que c'est toujours ça que je reprochais
un petit peu au marvel vos lacets c'est
des méchants voilà ils veulent dominer
le monde
ils veulent détruire le monde et ses
rêves être les plus forts le meilleur et
voilà est en hausse non il a un but bien
précis bon il est quand même un petit
peu mégalo un peu beaucoup mais il a un
but derrière voilà c'est il veut
rééquilibrer et c'est le dialogue avec
dr strange sur titan est vraiment bon en
fait genre thanos du coup ils vous
proposait de de faire une sorte de purge
équivalente entre les riches et les
pauvres là ya pas de favoritisme pour
que la planète puisse être relancé et
c'est vraiment pas bête en plus et c'est
intelligent il sait c'est compréhensif
en fête son but c'est compréhensif et
malheureusement il a été pris pour un
malade mental ils y ont dit mais tu es
un taré mon pauvre et du coup la planète
est morte il avait raison et du coup on
comprend la noce là dedans on le
comprend ils ont réussi à je trouve à
associer vraiment le côté
voilà c'est un méchant il veut quand
même être le plus fort parce que l'anoci
va quand même essayer de devenir une
sorte de dieu et en même temps avoir un
but quand même compréhensible et
et respectable parler parler viewer et
s'est parlé on part les avengers mais
bon pas vraiment non plus mais c'est
totalement compréhensible en vrai et
franchement chaque scène avec thanos est
bonne parce que c'est pas juste un gros
abrutis qui fait que de combattre et
cetera qui écrase tout le monde etc
non il ya du dialogue ya des choses
pertinentes etc
les phases avec camorra je trouvais que
c'était vraiment mais c'était puissant
surtout le moment où il a sacrifié en
fait
tanoh c'est humain comme tout le monde
et même si c'est un gros [ __ ] parce
que voilà ce qu'un gros [ __ ]
et enfin ils ont le voit pleurer quoi
enfin il est déchiré tout ça et c'est ça
le fait chier de devoir tuer sa sa fille
parce qu'ils l'aiment et ça c'est
quelque chose de rare pour un méchant
miss qui [ __ ] d'ailleurs je suis même
très je suis même très satisfait d'une
chose c'est que justement j'en parlais
dans le trois théories sur doctor
strange à la fin doctor strange c'est le
sait le seul magicien entre guillemets
du film chez les héros et justement je
me disais mais enfin il est complètement
over tchité enfin c'est pas possible il
va détruire tout le monde il suffit
qu'il ait des dégage quelqu'un voilà
comme il s'est passé claude renoir et le
dégage sur hoth par genre
en gros les landes où n'importe etc ou
dans un vide et y tombe etc
et puis au final c'est je trouve ça a
été bien ça a été bien le contrer on va
dire enfin ça a été bien ça a été bien
équilibrée et a mené parce que par
exemple avec le mec de l'ordre noir
qu'un petit peu magicien tout ça et
c'est qu'ils voulaient voler lapierre a
doctor strange et qui au final voilà il
utilisait la magie aussi il était même
au dessus de doctor strange quand même
et puis même thanos le combat contre
tanoh sa maman cas au docteur strange
est vraiment en confrontation avec la
noce et qui se battent en combat et tous
magie genre enfin c'était vraiment bien
stylé c'était bien amener etc
et puis je me disais mais c'est pareil
il a l'oeil d'agde à moto il va tout
défoncer fin c'est n'importe quoi
et puis au final on comprend pourquoi
ils l'utilisent pas au final c'est pour
la cacher pour pas que tanoh cela des
robes etc
donc c'était franchement c'était
intelligemment pensée et à mener et j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment bien
alors bien évidemment du coup j'ai eu
tout faux sur mes théories sais pas
c'est pas grave du tout ça ça ne me gêne
pas au contraire parce que du coup ça
prouve que j'ai eu beaucoup de surprises
que le film n'était pas prévisible
et du coup c'est cool quoi parce que je
pensais la première théorie du coup pas
tort vous voulez quand même récupérer
son marteau mais du coup il est il était
censé avoir hiverné viorne normalement
la place sa hache qui au final se faire
nommer stormbreaker
donnez partirions et du coup voilà après
la 2e théorie sa deuxième théorie attend
on va peut-être attendre un petit peu
pour en parler à ce que ça c'était
vraiment ça c'est vraiment le truc
ultime genre c'est ce qui m'a marqué de
ouf et du coup la troisième théorie avec
et la bombe a en fait thanos pour ceux
qui savent pas en gros dans les comics
thanos et amoureux de la mort en fait
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça c'est
d'ailleurs un gros but pour lui en fait
vu qui l'amour de la mort de récupérer
les pierres d'infinité pour justement
avoir à peu près les mêmes pouvoirs que
la mort est rééquilibré le monde etc
je fais partie d'un c'est l'un de ses
buts de réguler l'univers en fait même
s'il deviendra beaucoup plus fort que la
mort etc
et du coup pour moi l'homologue de la
mort c'était vraiment au genre est là
parce que du coup elle a été la déesse
de la mort etc et je trouvais ça bizarre
la façon dont tu es demeure donc j'étais
vraiment convaincu qu'ils reviendraient
parce que c'était quand même un
personnage vachement puissant tout ça et
ça me fait bizarre de la voir que sur un
film et tout d'un coup elle meurt comme
ça à la fin même pas vraiment par thor
donc c'était un peu étrange mais au
final maintenant je comprends et puis je
regrette pas d'avoir eu tort là dessus
mais on a pu voir le retour aussi de
crâne rouge
donc ça c'est pareil j'étais convaincu
crâne rouge trouvé ça bizarre ce que
[ __ ] il y en a plein qui me disaient
oui il est mort crâne rouge etc
mais je n'y croyais pas du tout vu que
le tc a été une sorte de portail je
savais que crâne rouge n'était pas mort
sans moi j'étais convaincu et qu'il
avait atterri autre part et du coup il
atterrit bon ça j'avoue je suis encore
peut-être un peu trop débutants là
dessus parce que du coup il a atterri je
sais pas trop où je me suis un peu mais
du coup il à moitié le gardien de la
pierre de l'âme parce qu'il a essayé de
convoiter les pierres mais c'est mario
semences j'ai pas souvenir qu'il voulait
avoir les pierres dans dents
dans le film de captain america le 1er
mai du coup c'est démarrant leur voir et
c'était plutôt sympathique et c'était
cohérent pour moi donc j'étais plutôt
content de le voir alors ensuite gros
gros étonnement quand même parce que
vient me voir je la voyais vraiment pas
mourir en fait ça m'a vraiment surpris
je m'attendais vraiment pas à ce qu'elle
meure et mes remarques c'était on est
quand même dans avengers infinity ward
voilà c'est l'affrontement ultime c'est
c'est en même temps c'est plutôt logique
et pourtant je suis sûr qu'elle
reviendrait dans les galaxies les
gardiens la galaxy 3 donc ça c'est c'est
bizarre mais au final ce fin ça prouve
enfin ce film trouve vraiment que les
héros ne gagne pas toujours
éclat il ya vraiment zéro moyen de
gagner là le film c'était vraiment ça on
garde
ils ont réussi à nous faire garder un
espoir tout du long comme quoi ils
réussirent est comme par exemple quand
ils sont tous sur thanos l'aïe qui a
réussit presque à lui à lui enlever le
gant de l'infini mais que star lors du
coup [ __ ] ils gâchent tout le film
tout le long nous nous fait croire quand
même un potentiel espoir et c'est
vraiment on va dire comme les avengers
en fait les avengers
aussi pense à un espoir en fait ils ont
toujours l'espoir aux fondeuses de
réussir même s'ils savent que c'est
impossible parce que banner dès le début
il l'aurait il leur dit c'est c'est ce
mec là c'est impossible de le vaincre et
où ils ont très bien retranscrit ça
parce que toulon on al'espoir j'étais
vraiment convaincu que thanos allait
quand même perdre à la fin même si
cheikh et 20 autres avengers après vous
m'avez tous dit oui mais c'est pas faim
tous entre guillemets mais j'ai eu
quelques commentaires qui me disaient
non ce n'est pas du tout une suite 7
avengers là c'est un autre film à part
avec thanos et du coup je me suis dit
bon ben ok moi ça veut dire que tu as
noces
enfin il va pas mourir mais il va être
vaincu
ils vont pas vraiment gagner enfin il va
pas vraiment gagner tout ça et c est du
coup toulon tel espoir que les avengers
réussissent même si il va y avoir des
pertes et thuc les avengers vont réussir
hélas et c'est une scène incroyable moi
je trouve c'est celle du bois kanda ce
que du coup un combat mais 2 ouvre un
gros combat d'armes et tout pour
défendre vision parce que si vision de
la dernière pierre c'est fini qu'on a un
gros c'est mort c'est totalement fini et
c'est vraiment un gros combat ça dure au
moins 15 minutes 20 minutes de film etc
il se passe des trucs de ouf des combats
de ouf et cetera des scènes de ouf
puis thanos récupère la dernière pierre
via docteur strange qui d'ailleurs dit à
tony stark que c'était le seul moyen
voit ça on va en reparler un petit peu
après et au final danos arrive et c'est
cette scène prouve vraiment ou trouve
vraiment que thanos et surpuissante sais
c'est qu'on peut rien faire on peut on
ne peut pas le vaincre et on ne peut
rien faire et thanos du coup arrive ils
réussissent à détruire la gemme coûte
que coûte ces genres ça prend un temps
fou et tout est à nos cieux il arrive
tac en retour dans le temps y tue vision
il chope la pierre et la prends c'est ça
prouve vraiment fins été incroyable que
tanoh c'était vraiment un méchant
invincible vraiment invincible qu'il
était vraiment le point culminant du mc
est le méchant ultime et bordel ce que
c'était incroyable et maintenant bon on
va attaquer vraiment enfin pour parce
qu'on va pas on va pas tourner autour du
pot 3 heures faut vraiment qu'on parle
de la fin est tous des suppositions ce
que je me suis renseigné tout va y avoir
un trois théories qui va sortir là dès
la semaine prochaine parce que je peux
pas attendre d'en parler là j'ai trop
envie d'en parler je me suis déjà
intéressé 2 où j'ai déjà des théories en
tête que je me suis créé moi même donc
tort
arrive coûte que coûte thor là il
devient surpuissant c'est exactement un
petit peu comme j'ai dit à ma vidéo là
si thor récupère son marteau ben là
c'est même encore mieux que son marteau
avec son pouvoir du tonnerre vraiment
qu'il a appris lors de taurinya rock à
contrôler et c'est à éveiller vraiment
là il est vraiment surpuissant à tel
point qui réussit à tuer thanos il ya
aussi à toute la noce après il ya la
scène celle là je n'ai pas trop compris
j'avoue je suis peut-être encore un peu
novice là dedans mais je me dis que cela
grâce à la pierre de l'amant gros thanos
ne meurt pas en fait je sais pas si
c'est dû parce que il a sacrifié camorra
et cetera où ça fonctionne peut-être un
peu comme un orque russe je sais pas
trop vu qu'il a sacrifié gamme aura et
du coup il survit et là l'hécatombe
[Musique]
claquement de doigts et ska et là je
m'attendais vraiment pas je connaisse et
les conséquences tout ça et c'est je
savais exactement ce qui allait se
passer si il claqué des doigts et qu'il
arrivait à avoir les pierres mais là
c'est c'est la scène la plus incroyable
genre j'ai même vu des gens au cinéma
qui pleurait genre vraiment j'ai vu des
gens au cinéma qui pleurait quoi mais
j'étais vraiment sur le cul j'étais
bouche bée je ne m'attendais vraiment
pas à ce que thanos réussissent et
pourtant ça semblait logique vu que
chaque film marvel est là pour
introduire un héros et s'est vu que ce
film là et pour introduire thanos thanos
devait gagner
enfin c'est une sorte de logique mais je
m'attendais vraiment pas à ce qu'il
réussisse en fait
et du coup
l'hécatombe je m'attendais vraiment pas
à ça je savais qu'il y aurait des morts
alors d'ailleurs c'était même rigolo ce
qu on a rigolé à la fin du la séance de
ce que j'ai dis bah j'ai sommes un peu
parce que du coup j'ai fait une théorie
ou jeudi que iron man va mourir captain
america va mourir et vision et au final
captain america iron man sont limite les
deux seuls héros qui reste c'est du coup
c'est vraiment l'hécatombe
les héros disparaissent chacun leur tour
la moitié des héros du coup est ce que
c'est vraiment le 50/50 donc environ 3
milliards 5 d'êtres humains
disparaissent d'un coup donc ses limites
comme si tu avais une chance sur deux à
moitié tu vois et du coup temps plein
deux héros qui disparaissent on les voit
un indice paraître est là tu dis mais
non elles sont pas réellement mort
bah si et franchement cette scène elle
était vraiment incroyable notamment mois
ce qui là où j'ai trouvé vraiment lourde
en émotions et vraiment ça m'a pris le
coeur c'était jour bas spider man en
fait genre quand spider man il a
conscience voilà il se sent tout bizarre
ils voient les autres partir enfin ouais
il voit certains autres partir et puis
là il a conscience que la voilà il sent
pas bien et que c'est lui qui va mourir
enfin il va dans les bras de tony stark
et où les limites en pleurs il y en a
il a peur il a peur de mourir il ne peut
rien faire il est obligé de mourir parce
que thanos en a décidé ainsi
c'était une scène tellement tragique est
incroyable je me suis vraiment senti
[ __ ] imagine ça nous arrive quoi ça
m'a vraiment bouleversée et c'était
cette scène est un crime dont mister qui
faisait pas du tout le malin alors que
lui pourtant enfin il est toujours assez
sûr de lui et ses îles et il est très un
peu mégalo aussi et enfin égocentrique
et du coup le fin ça m'a vraiment
perturbé cette scène et puis la scène de
fin vraiment où on voit ta noski qui se
réveille à moitié qui sort de sa hutte
et que là le monde refleurit etc
c'est vraiment la scène thanos a réussi
thanos a atteint son but
il a réussi et voilà
terminer fin là je me suis resté genre
je suis resté au moins cinq minutes
comme ça dans le cinéma j'étais bien en
attendant la scène post générique parce
que du coup il ya toujours une scène
afin dé marvel alors du coup j'étais
vraiment mais comme ça je parlait plus
j'étais vraiment mais georges était sous
le choc j'étais bouche bée j'avais le
cul par terre bien au fond de mon siège
l'âge était terrassé
j'étais vraiment de terrasser parce que
surtout que dans ma tête en fait vu que
j'arrête pas de faire des recherches et
tout pour les vidéos tout ça je me suis
dit bon il ya dr strange de en 2020 via
les gardiens la galaxy 3 en 2020 black
panther il est nouveau il vient
d'arriver
ça va être la dernière fois qu'on le
voit spider man aussi il va y avoir le
coming deux pareils vers 2020
c'est je trouvais ça vraiment bizarre en
fait c'est je trouve ça vraiment étrange
et là du coup je les vois tous un à
partir dont dr french doctor strange qui
est mon héros préférés je le vois partir
je me dis voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
est vraiment chez nous c'est pas normal
quoi et pourtant j'étais je comprenais
plus j'étais là j'étais en mode mais
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible ça
c'est pas possible
j'y croyais pas je n'y croyais pas
bordel et puis du coup après je suis
sortie du cinéma tout ça et cetera bon
bah il ya eu prescription me suis dit
[ __ ] le film était vraiment où j'étais
vraiment pas déçu j'ai été vraiment un
réel fans du film c'est ça que j'aime
dans les abonnements c'est que c'est pas
juste du combat brut est débile de héros
qui tabasse des méchants et cetera
c'est vraiment un côté humain il ya un
côté il ya du dialogue des dialogues
fort en plus ce genre notamment
franchement camorra et anneaux c'était
une relation vraiment compliqué et c'est
même staller des gammes aura c'était
assez incroyable
pareil même l'humour dans le film il
était bien amener enfin donc c'est que
les gardiens la galaxie trois ils font
tous faim avec bernadette la galaxie 3es
derrière la galaxie ils font toujours
les cons ils font très très souvent les
cons enfin on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
second degré donc c'était pas
c'était pas du tout gênant tort c'est
pareil les un petit côté des bills
parfois c'est pas du tout gênant c'était
c'était ce n'est pas dérangeant même le
moment avec captain america quand il ya
juste at-elle route et la jeu s'appelle
steve rogers
enfin cesser des petits détails mais
c'est marrant c'est bien amener ce n'est
pas comme dans star wars 8 c'était je
trouvais ça vraiment bizarre en star
wars 8 ça faisait pas rire là c'était
marrant j'ai même rigolé et ce qui m'a
fait rêver bon après j'avais pas vu
black panther donc je savais pas trop
mais ça m'a fait vraiment rire aussi
c'était genre de dans le wakanda genre
black panther tout ça je les voyais dès
qu'ils se parlaient entre eux ils
étaient là ouais mon frère je suis dit
c'est tellement cliché un peu faim pas
raciste non plus mais genre tellement
cliché un peu noir tout ça genre un
maudit se disent tous c'est mon frère
j'étais mort de rire là dessus mais
après j'ai pas vu black panthères donc
c'était sa soeur apparemment donc ça ça
m'a fait chier c'est un petit frein pour
moi mais du coup elle c'était sa soeur
et c'est donc normal qu'elle l'appelait
mon frère mais ça ça m'a fait tellement
rire et puis du coup bas il ya eu la
scène post générique alors du coup j'ai
pas compris trop sur le coup parce que
je me suis plus intéressé après on va
dire j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
aujourd'hui je vous le cache pas et du
coup c'est ça va être donc nick fury
disparaît et puis là il a réussi à
envoyer un signal à quelqu'un est là du
coup captain marvel
j'avais pas reconnu au début l'insigne
etc je savais pas trop jaloux je me
demandais c'est chelou et là du coup
captain marvel dont captain marvel et du
coup ce que le film laisse supposer du
couvre maintenant tu es horizon un petit
peu ce que supposé maintenant c'est que
le film
c'est tout repose sur captain marvel en
fait captain marvel va va sauver le truc
c'est ce qui est normalement prévu
surtout que captain marvel et le
prochain film
après ant man et la guêpe qui sort cet
été il me semble et du coup le film
hitman et la guerre je pense du coup ça
va être un film du coup et que la moitié
des héros enfin la moitié des roues
seront là la moitié de l'humanité sera
seulement là aussi et puis va affronter
du coup l'ennemi que la guêpe c'est une
femme il me semble et puis du coup il y
aura captain marvel on c'est une fille
et il va y avoir aussi jude law qui va
jouer
marc vesle du coup ça c'est pareil je
connais pas trop j'ai essayé de regarder
un petit peu donc il me semble que julo
du coup marvel c'est le sait le méchant
et du coup captain marvel qui est j'ai
oublié son nom donne woerth je crois je
me souviens plus du nom de la fille et
du coup qui du coup c'est ça qui va
introduire quoi et du coup elle va elle
va apparaître et surtout ce qui
m'intrigue mois le plus c'est que moi
enfin c'est pas elle en fait qui va
faire leur tour pour moi j'en parlerai
plus en la vidéo 3 0 et que je vais
faire mais c'est vraiment il ya un
personnage qui a été utilisée aussi dans
une scène post générique des gardiens la
galaxy 3 et dans les comics je me suis
renseigné tout ça c'est un mec qui a
déjà vaincu thanos en fait à moitié
enfin c'est lily c'est lui qui lui a
retiré le gant de l'infini
il a tabassé un petit peu c'est adam
warlock et adam warnock il a été teasé
dans les gardiens la galaxy 3 en scène
post générique c'est en gros une sorte
de vision c'est comme vision mais en
nettement plus amélioré en nettement
plus poussée et c'est un mec qui a
vaincu la noce dans les comics en fait
et qu'il a retiré le gant de l'infini
du coup pour moi ce serait lui qui est
le dernier espoir en fait qui pourrait
potentiellement sauver tout le monde
et du coup il y aura certainement un
rapport à captain marvel je sais pas
trop si dans les comics s'ils se
connaissent et c'est ce que ça s'inspire
comme un petit peu des comics je pense
aux collectionneurs avec la pierre de
pierre ii
pas de lame je sais plus quelle pierre
et là le collectionneur mais en gros
thanos le récupère sur lui et voilà quoi
mais voilà pour moi c'est vraiment adam
warlock qui va être le dernier espoir
pour sauver tout le monde de thanos et
du coup après je sais pas trop si l'on a
fini en gros ça peut fonctionner en
inversant le truc mais du coup ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'ils vont les héros vont
revenir en fait donc c'est toujours
quand même une happy end mais ce film
était vraiment bon il ya quand même y
aura comme une api rennes en fait
avengers cad sera la suite en fait la
suite directe parce qu'il y aura entre
maniora captain marvel et un autre film
il me semble je sais plus où
mais en tout cas il y aura deux trois
films avant donc ce sera quand même dans
cet univers après une finity war et du
cou adam warlock pour moi est le dernier
espoir
il est le dernier espoir avec captain
marvel on a dû ou en fait et je vous en
parlerai dans la prochaine vidéo théorie
sur du coup ça sera sur une infiniti
voir aussi à ce que j'ai j'ai vraiment
envie d'en parler je suis vraiment à y
payer deux ou flash eco mandingue et
puis il ya aussi les restes d euros bien
évidemment mais je suis très curieux
j'ai envie de voir ce qui va se passer
tout ça je suis je suis encore sur le
client fait j'ai encore les images de
chaque héros qui disparaît un à un et
c'est vraiment incroyable et toute façon
là où la happy end est véridique c'est
la phrase de doctor strange en fait dr
strange a vu plusieurs futures etc
il en a vu 14 millions il précise et il
a dit qu'il ya seulement 1 où ils
réussissent et du coup c'est un avenir
où thanos alessi pierre en fait vous est
pour ça qu il a donné la pierre du temps
doctor strange puisque c'est le seul
moyen apparemment de de pouvoir
potentiellement le vaincre et réussir
mais en tout cas chaque héros reviendra
et c'est sûr parce que les c'est ça le
problème de marvel c'est le défaut c'est
que les films sont annoncés beaucoup
trop à l'avance parce que là du coup on
sait qu'il y aura docteur strange 2 ou
coming deux spider man 2 par an les
gardiens la galaxy 3 des trucs comme ça
donc c'est évident qu'ils vont revenir
c'est évident mais bon sans quoi ce film
m'a écouté j'ai pas vraiment grand chose
à vous dire de plus j'étais vraiment fan
donc écouter n'hésitez pas à répondre
aux sondages dans la description et à
participer au concours sur twitter
c'est vraiment pour vous je le fais et
puis le sondage ça peut être vraiment
intéressant quel film
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo on se retrouve très prochainement
du coup pour le live de dimanche et puis
pour les vidéos théorie c'était cet
argot rock [ __ ] qu'est ce que t'as
noces et charismatique même encore plus
que dark vador aller s'était targuée
rock de l'année avec vous allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]